today's topic tell me you have pretty
privilege without actually telling me
that you have pretty privilege
oh i have a story so when i was 22 i
randomly moved to la with no plan no
clue where i was going to live nothing i
get down there and i ask one of my
girlfriends if she wants to hang out so
while we're hanging out we get to
chatting and she goes hey why don't you
just live with me in the model house for
the summer and i didn't know what that
was at the time but all it is is a
mansion in the hills where models get to
live there rent free and in exchange
they just have to go to clubs twice a
week and look cute
that's it they uber you there you look
cute you stand around usually and then
you go home
and i gotta live there for an entire
summer
because she sent her agent photos of me
and my height and i just gotta live
there it was so much fun i gotta meet ed
westwick from gossip girl chuck bass
i have so many stories from that house
yeah
pretty prelude is a real thing and also
just peep game
you see how somebody put him up in a
mansion paid all this money just for
them to be around them because there's
somebody with a lot of money and a lot
of value who recognizes the value of
adding hot women around then it happened
is that
these girls are not even [ __ ] right
no it's not even that is that in a club
environment tell them you're a club oh
you're a bouncer right yeah you've been
to a lot of big events yes
black's on point but it's not only that
i work in a five-star res a five-star
hotel i've worked in services i've
worked in in different um
uh events as well as security and you
said you have to understand these girls
and the girl that's talking she's
probably she's not even sleeping with
nobody she's not paid to sleep with
nobody it's just that whenever you have
a club okay
you want to have beautiful women because
that's going to attract men because
that's a man that's going to pay bottles
and pay things and spend money in your
club it's like you know you want to have
good looking strippers in your club so
that they bring money in it is the same
thing but these girls are not strippers
they're just there to
they're basically furniture they're
furniture that look good it's like if i
told you let's go to that club the first
the furniture is nice
that's what it is
they're paid to look good
paintings on a wall so when you go there
you try to howl at them the girls they
might say yes the girls might say no but
they're not paid for that they're just
paid to be there because it increased
the value of the club
crazy like that because normal
patrons
is not going to cut it they need a con
consistency you see how mcdonald's the
fries at mcdonald's no matter where you
go in mcdonald's is the same fries no
matter consistency so you
that's what they is so they want the
same fries every week
everywhere it's consistent at that club
the girls are fries consistent
and uh yeah it has a huge benefit from a
status standpoint and listen some of
these girls don't a lot of them do they
do extra work okay
all these mansions for a lot of them is
not free
and sometimes it's not even directly but
once you just come back over me we need
to talk
they know what time it is they want to
stay in that mansion they want to have a
good time they want to meet the guys
from gossip girl okay so just know that
when people say pretty privilege it's
like the idea that you can just change
financial brackets that you can gain
these like housing privileges bro just
from
the house in the hills for a summer
in beverly hills you're talking about
tens of thousands of dollars on the low
end i'm done here
and you live there rent free
just because of your beauty and you
probably could have lived there longer
if you were willing to do more work yeah
so
just be mindful that when people talk
about what this thing is it's real it's
real it exists forget paying for drinks
all night forget i've seen people have
their tuitions paid and not even offer
anything back in return because dudes
are willing to pay that much just to
walk around go to dinner with them yeah
yes just because you want to be seen
i seen a girl get on the phone and just
talk to a dude and this guy paypaled her
thousands of dollars just because she
said you little dirty
she started talking [ __ ] to him yeah
that was his game that's right you want
to be dominated by attractive women so
understand it doesn't mean that everyone
who's pretty and attractive doesn't deal
with stuff i 100 acknowledge that as an
attractive woman who maybe wants to just
chill it is annoying to walk around have
dudes constantly after you constantly
sexualizing you from a young age and
getting on your case i will never deny
that that dark side exists it would be
very hard if you like want to be a
principled person who's also attractive
and you have to deal with all this
unnecessary nonsense people not actually
wanting to be your friend but being
close to you just because you're
attractive i get that that's why and
being hated on because you are beautiful
so i'm not saying there's not an other
side to that point i acknowledge that
being pretty isn't always perfect but
it exists the privileges is here and
it's real and you don't want to be ugly
instead of attracting oh yeah you
wouldn't get the same person and that's
why i did change it higher quickly
speaking so um that's that's the main
thing but her story she was really
candid and i appreciate her telling like
yo this is what happened and i know it's
because of my privilege so she's really
cool you know i appreciate the fact that
you know she was open about it yeah
thank you very much for that exactly
tell me you have pretty privilege
without actually telling me that you
have pretty privilege sometimes when me
and my friends are around a group of guy
they'll um intentionally ignore me and
only talk to my friends and pretend that
i'm not there and i think it's because
um
they're too nervous to come talk to me
because they think i'm cute
you're great you're [ __ ] great i love
this yo yo yo you i don't know who the
who is you're amazing
daddy
you're
great awesome you're amazing shout out
to this girl yo shout out to you my girl
perfect isn't it
hi
would you like to play some dungeons and
dragons later
he sent me you were a little drunk last
night so i left you on the couch but i
made some pancakes for you
this is yeah right in front of you
sometimes i wake up beside a girl you
know me in bed yeah it's like oh and
then they're just waking up like good
boarding
and they're like stop and i'm like
please please touch me
i don't know i got certain characters
that girl is amazing yeah [ __ ] it i
appreciate that kind of self-awareness
you know if you can laugh at yourself
for being uh unattractive or whatnot
then good for you do you feel bad for
you you need to be able to have that
laugh so shout out to her and i think
that's uh pretty much all i just have
anything else you want to add no no
please preach
tell us something more no the audience
feels like get the [ __ ] out of having
more to say
[ __ ] christ
why am i turning into a dinosaur
don't touch me no how do you fix that
but doesn't let you talk enough
[Laughter]
there is this network of apps that are
essentially beauty passes so if you're a
model or just like a pretty girl or an
influencer you can apply to get in there
like exclusive so not everyone gets
accepted but you apply to get in and if
you get in there's a [ __ ] ton of
businesses restaurants like massages
facials lip injections makeup clothes
whatever haircuts everything
yoga classes pilates everything um that
you can get for free just if you like
tag them on an instagram story so if you
follow models that post like joe and the
juice and pilates on their story every
single day
they're not paying for that
[Music]
go